uh hello
so i'm elise cardinale we'll be
uh starting this discussion now so
uh i am a transparent nephrologist at
the schum
and an independent researcher at the
sierra
and today i will be presenting uh with
my
colleague tristan silva and i'll let him
introduce himself
um so hi everyone my name is tristan
silva
i'm a phd student at the mila lab
from university of montreal supervised
by joshua banjo
and i've worked in the past on survival
data in particular using
deep neural networks to address the
different issues
we currently have when modeling survival
data
so today trista and i will be talking to
you
about the development of a clinical
decision support tool
to help transplant physician and
transplant candidates
decide on whether to accept or decline
an offer for kidney transplantation
so this is a collab collaborative work
as you can see
and uh tristar and margo have been very
much
involved in the deep learning models
that tristan will be talking to about
later on
so chronic kidney disease is on the rise
in canada
and what i want to point out to you on
this slide is that
this is happening mostly in an elderly
population
with patients over 65 comprising the
most new
cases and when the kidneys fail
well some form of renal replacement
therapy
must be undertaken and that can be in
the form of hemodialysis
but of course hemodialysis is quite
cumbersome because it means coming to
the hospital
three times per week for four hours
we can also do uh dialysis through the
peritoneal membrane
but this is also quite cumbersome and
uh the best treatment of course is
kidney transplantation
and as we have an aging
population with chronic kidney disease
we also have an aging population
of a kidney transplant candidates
and so why is kidney transplantation the
best treatment for
renal replacement therapy well first of
all it
improves quality of life of course but
it also
improves life expectancy and when we
look at the full cohort we can see a
gain
in life expectancy of 10 years with
transplantation
in comparison to remaining on dialysis
so
we would like to be able to perform
kidney transplantations for
every eligible chronic kidney disease
patient however
there is a problem in that there is a
great
gap a great discrepancy between the
demand
for organs and the number of
transplantations that we can perform
on a yearly basis and so
how do we fill that gap and make sure
that
every eligible candidate gets a
transplantation
so the the eye in an ideal world this
would be
through living donation uh but the
problem is that
most kidney transplant recipients do not
have
a living donor available and 60
of kidney transplantations originate
from deceased donors in canada
and in the province of quebec that
reaches a figure of 80
so so we must do most transplantation
with deceased donors and so another way
to increase the number of
transplantation and meet that gap
is by increasing the deceased donor pool
how can we do this
so we can try to utilize for
transplantation
kidneys that originate from patients
who have risk features for lower
long-term graft survival so here i'm
talking about
older donors donors with some
comorbidities for instance hypertension
diabetes
or who have stroke as cause of death and
the idea of using
these donors for transplantation is not
new we already perform these
transplantations
but we know that we could optimize
utilization of these donors because more
than 20 of these donors are recovered
but
not transplanted in the end
so just to let you know a little bit
about
the context so that you can understand
better the tool
that we're developing so in canada organ
allocation is based on a provincial
basis
so there are organ donation organization
audios which manage all offers so what
happens for instance in the province of
quebec
our odo is translate and what happens is
that when a deceased donor becomes
available transplant quebec will run an
algorithm and
give a score to each kidney transplant
candidate
who is wait listed in the province of
quebec
and then they the transplant quebec
coordinators
will start calling centers where the
candidates are listed
in a descending order of the score
until both kidneys are accepted or
rejected
and so this score varies by province but
in quebec here are the elements
that are uh given points for in the
score so for instance wait time on
dialysis so the longer you've waited
the more points you get as a candidate
um
elevated nthl antibodies this is because
uh these patients are usually harder to
match so we give them points when we
find a good match
recipient age the younger the more
points match
so closeness and age between recipient
and donor age
and so that's important here um for the
that points are given for this closest
age uh
in the tool that we're about to develop
and i'll come back to that later
and finally they give points for
compatibility and tissue
typing between the donor and the
recipient and so
the odo does the allocation but
in the end the final decision to accept
or refuse the offer from the o from the
odo
belongs to the transplant physician
in collaboration with the transplant
candidate and this
should be in a pro cell process which is
called shared decision making
where the transplant physician should be
uh
providing the patient with the relevant
information
for him or her to make the proper
decision
of accepting or refusing based on his
values
and what's important to
the candidate but the problem right now
is that the quality of the relevant
information
is not very high and so there
is a need for a tool to guide
inform to guide physicians so that they
can transmit the proper
information to patients and
because this the quality of the
information
is not very high there is important
variability in clinical practice
in organs that are accepted or refused
and we know that there is variability by
center and also by physician and this
has been described uh
a bit everywhere around the world and
for those who practice and get back it's
very clear that there is variability by
center
and so in order to
fill that gap between organ demand and
offer
the canadian blood services is currently
heading a national committee
that has a mandate of optimizing organ
utilization so what does that mean
it means that we're going to be trying
to use more of these high-risk donors
and of course
we're not talking about you know giving
them to children or very young adults
because we know they have a lower
potential for long-term grasp survival
but we're since we're facing also an
uh an aging kidney transplant candidate
population
these are kidneys that could provide a
dialysis free survival to our older
candidates but at the same time if we're
going to do this
we need to be communicating the risk of
accepting or refusing an organ
in a very um in a very detailed fashion
so that the recipient the intended
recipient can
take the best decision and so to decide
if we're going to accept or refuse a
high-risk donor
one has to weigh the pros and cons of
accepting or refusing so
if we accept this kind of offer the pros
are that there's no more dialysis now
which ex
certainly will increase quality of life
and life expectancy
but the cons are that you're accepting a
high risk donor so
this could lead to shorter graft
survival so earlier return to dialysis
and worse kidney function but we know
that both these
things are risk factors for
cardiovascular disease so
there are counts but at the same time we
have to wonder
how much shorter the graft survival
with the current offer compared to what
could be
offered to me in general because as i
was telling you earlier there is
age matching there are points for age
matching between the donor and the
recipient
so if i'm a 70 year old candidate and
i'm waiting for that 20 year old donor
i may be waiting a long time and more
wait time
is not a healthy choice so
if we decide to refuse that offer then
the pros
are that eventually we may get a better
kidney hopefully uh
in a short term on a short term basis
but the cons
if we refuse is that uh the candidate
will have to keep on waiting
which reduces both life expectancy and
quality of life and then the candidate
has to wonder will i make it to
transplant will i die on the wait list
will i be permanently removed and
if does not happen how long will i wait
to have a better offer
so in our effort to build this clinical
decision support tool
first we did an end user needs
assessment
so what we did is that we performed some
focus groups
with kidney trust plan candidates and
recipients in montreal
and we also did semi-directed interviews
with key opinion leaders across the
country
and what we found out is that the
appetite
of patients for a web-based tool that
they could be using
was very low that was our initial
intention but
what we found from these focus groups is
that our patients
have placed great trust in their medical
team
and what they expect is that their
transplant physician
will make the information the relevant
information easily
and provide it to them so that they can
be informed
on their choice they did not wish to to
use the tool themselves
and we have to remember why the offer is
a very
emotional moment for them and so they're
certainly not thinking in the way
they're
usually uh thinking because of this uh
emotional turmoil let's say
and so in this clinical
decision support tool our idea
is that three key points of information
will be provided the first one is if we
accept the current offer based on the
donor and intended recipient
characteristics
how long can we expect this graph to
work so how long do we expect that the
patient will be alive
and off dialysis the second point of
information
is if we decline the current offer
how long are we expected to wait for a
next offer and what's the relative
quality of that next offer
compared to the current one because we
don't want to wait for nothing we want
to wait for a better offer
and the third point of information is a
final suggestion by the tool to accept
or decline the offer
based on selecting the alternative which
will maximize
survival with a functioning graph so
survival
of dilysis from the time of the initial
office
offer so we
have been working in the past two or
three years
on the first two points uh the graft
survival prediction
and the prediction of wait time if the
offer is refused and
first we will be
talking to you about the expected graft
survival if the offer is accepted
and i will let tristan present this part
which is a very much machine learning
deep learning part all right thank you
louise uh
can you move to the next uh slide please
okay so uh as louise mentioned one of
the big components of the uh
the tool is actually being able to
predict uh the survival
probability of a graft so
uh what we did was uh this is work from
a few years back continuing up to today
what we did was uh we considered the
uh srtr cohort study
and uh we considered single kidney
transplantations
ranging from you know dates between uh
january 1st 2000 and december 31st 2014
and uh we defined a censorship variable
based on
on essentially if the event occurred
after a certain date
and we did not exclude any previous
organ transplants
and the outcome we were predicting
before was
the overall wrap survival which means
that
essentially we're looking at a variable
which is
uh surviv grab does not survive if for
example you have patient death return to
dialysis
or a need for a re-transplantation
and we're considering in this work a set
of variables comprising varicose
pertaining to the recipient
variables pertaining to the donor and
finally variables that are linked to
both
such as the hla mismatch
next slide please so essentially
uh to discuss about this model it's
interesting to go back to the context of
when it was
first uh introduced so essentially what
we did was
uh and this is work dating from 2016
2017
we so at the time we didn't have too
many approaches
on uh deep neural networks applied to
survival analysis in fact we were i
guess
the second work and the first one to
actually introduce
a more complex uh formulation of the fox
loss
the cox log likelihood loss essentially
you have two diff so so this can be seen
as a general machine learning problem
following the
like the following assumptions you have
a target
and you have another variable which is
whether or not your event is censored so
the target would simply be
at this point in time you have an event
an event such as patient death or any
other
any of the other aforementioned events
and censoring simply means that
after this specific point in time
you no longer have any information on
the patient because potentially the
patient has
left the study or has disappeared for
some reason but it does not mean that
the patient has died simply means you
have no information
and what empirically we found is that it
was of course very important to not only
take into account the patients for which
we
have definitive information but the
patients for which we only have partial
information in the form of
all of the survival up to the censoring
time
and what we did was essentially a
multitasking network where we
uh predicted two things in this
formulation
the first one was a ranking glass based
on
a predicted score based on an
intermediate layer of the network
and the second loss was simply a
survival prediction loss based
on uh essentially the the the coxswain
look like the outlaws um
and so of course as input to this model
we have
uh the different features that i
discussed before
uh can you go to the next slide please
okay and so what was really interesting
with this work is that we we actually
got some very good improvements uh
compared to other models so i'll discuss
quickly the baselines that we that we
used
uh so cox efference is simply efferent's
approximation
to uh the cox log-likelihood loss the
cox clock-like weight loss is let's say
the the gold standard for survival
prediction
and affron's approximation is simply a
modification to the laws
to help it better take into account
censoring that can occur
sorry um overlap between times if you
have multiple events at the same time
timestamp then that complicates the
computation of the loss and reference
approximation
to some extent solves uh this mlp cox
was simply
uh the first work on survival analysis
applied to deep neural networks
and mlp uh cocceferens would be
simply efference survival loss and
finally
random survival forests was at that time
close to the state of the art for
smaller data sets and our model as i
mentioned before is a hybrid of
coccyx loss and a specific
survival score that we added
next slide please
uh so i'll go over the the advantages
real
quick so uh first of all we don't need
extensive data processing we also get
good improvements in performance with
this approach
we're able to take into account the full
set of information available so donor
and recipient characteristics
and finally we took an approach where
we're able to predict the survival time
directly as opposed to simply a survival
score
as would for example cox is default
log likelihood as as cox's default block
that you
would predict so this is actually very
useful if you're a clinician and you
want to
give the patient some information on you
know their expected graft survival as
opposed to simply saying
well you know you're high risk you're
low risk so the disadvantages
is mostly that we're using uh american
data
which compared to the data in other
countries has a significant domain shift
there's a lot of features which you
might not have in different countries
which might
you know consider different inputs and
also
uh the survival rate is generally lower
which can be due to
a reporting bias so for example uh
american hospitals are forced to report
uh deaths or any negative events
whereas hospitals and other countries
might not have to so this could bias the
output
but also it could simply be to overall
higher survival in countries such as for
example canada
and uh i should mention as a final note
that
we are working on improving this model
continuously
ideas that we worked on after this idea
were mostly
around improving the time prediction
which is of course very important for
the aforementioned
model we we got a workshop paper
at icml uh discussing
the idea of applying this with an earth
mover's distance
where the muscle stand distance between
your survival distribution over time and
ground truth survival distribution
is computed that gained a large
improvement over
time prediction and we're also
considering what happens in a more
realistic case where for example remodel
is trained
but you have data coming in regularly in
the form of simply hospitals
every day adding more patients and more
data how do you improve your model in a
way that
does not disrupt past performance
and uh so i'm i'm done thank you
okay and so i'll be talking about the
second point of information
that our tool will provide now and so
this was work that was done
by uh jean el veler a master student
under the supervision of andrea ludi at
the corporal technique
and so the problem here is to say so we
have an offer at
time t 0 and we want to estimate the
time to the next offer and the
quality of that next offer and so what
uh
jeannette did is that he used
data real real life data from cosmon
quebec 2012 to 2017
and he uh built a model
with poisson distribution where what he
did is that
he looked to estimate future offers
he looked at the arrival of kidneys that
had occurred in the two years previous
to the current offer
and then of course he only kept
those kidneys that could have gone to a
recipient so for instance
he excluded those that had been abl
ineligible he excluded those whose score
was so low that they wouldn't have never
been offered to
our current recipient and he
also made a correction for the level of
anti-hla antibodies or cpra we call them
because we know
that these patients are harder to match
so he also corrected for that
and he updated
all the predictions for wait time on uh
dialysis because you get
more points as uh time goes on
on the wait list and this allowed him
to predict the arrival the future of
arrival
of kidneys after a specific offer that
was refused
and with these kidneys he could also
calculate the kidney donor risk
index score which is a score that's
quite often used in the united states
and gives an approximate quality of
donor
and we could compare the potential
future offers to the current offers in
terms of quality
and now i just want to uh to say a word
about our industrial partner and so
how this came along was that the federal
ministry of innovation science and
industry and the cihr
funded a competition through innovative
solutions canada in 2019
and this was for canadian companies to
work with in the
investigators of the cdtrp the canadian
donation
and transplantation research program to
uh
develop a phase one study proof of
principle study that would enhance the
use of ai
in the field of organ transplantation
and donation and so crazy
which is a company who does the i.t work
for transplant quebec
won funds for this phase one study and
we started working with them and we're
halfway through
the phrase one study at present time
and what we're focusing on for the phase
one study is a technology transfer
of the developed models for the
prediction of wait time if
a current offer is refused and its
quality and
we've been working on that and have
three more months to complete
this study so uh all that
we've been talking about uh for now and
tristan
mentioned a little bit about this but we
we're talking about for now a static
tool but of course
um in an ideal world this would become
a dynamic tool a learning system where
we could have
access to other data sources canadian
data
euro transplant data uk data australian
data so there are registries a bit
everywhere
uh on a kidney transplant outcomes
which could uh help us refine
our predictions if we had access to uh
to
real-time data eventually
again this in canada um there is the
problem of
confidentiality because our our registry
does not give a lot of
information on donor and recipient
characteristics but this
data is found at the level of the
centers so
this may be an eventual development
and uh here i would like to present to
you the the team so of course as i was
saying this is a collaboratory for work
so atletico polytechnic
andrea who supervised um jean noel
doing the the time to next offer work
at mila here is marco and trista
who were supervised by joshua banjo to
do the machine learning
part with the help of also joseph
polkowen
and at the sierra shemwell myself and
malicion alforte
and we did also the the focus groups and
the
the qualitative work on this project
so uh we will now be very happy
uh both uh uh
fisa and i to take the questions
so i guess that i'm going to
read the questions so ouda is asking
do you account for the surgeon's
performance in the transplantation
procedure in your training data if so
how does the learning curve seniority
level impact the model that's very
interesting
no the answer is no um
we i do not believe that
this is available in srtr to my
knowledge
and i do not believe that it would be
easily accessible in any
canadian data either and how do you
compare your results to the current
state and tools used by doctors in the
hospital
well so we have never you know we have
not
used our tool yet because it is not
fully developed but what i can say about
the current clinical practice which i
which i do every day is that
at current time the discussions around
the
offer are very very much
um you know very very variable
because what happens is that there's no
specific script
there's no uh information that should
absolutely be told to patients so it's a
bit like
more an art than the science and that's
uh something that we're trying to fix
and um you know so i have some
colleagues who will say
uh for instance you know we have a good
kidney for you
and that's that and other colleagues
will
uh go a bit in more details by providing
uh you know the kdri and what it means
in terms of percentage of survival at
this or
at the at you know five or ten years but
we have nothing to tell you what happens
if you refuse at present time which is
why
we think this is a significant
addition to the current clinical
practice
the second question is can we access the
presentations recording
uh i i do not know but uh certainly uh
the organizers can answer uh this
oh i see that there is
another question so
could you expand on why the access to
the organ repository data is problematic
with the use of federated learning to
gather data dynamically without breaking
silos build solution a the answer is yes
that would be run wonderful so i think
there are so so
first of all what we use is srtr so srtr
is available upon demand uh upon you
know presentation of a
research project with approval from a
proper
uh ethics committee and
um and we have to pay to use it it's not
very expensive but but it it
is easily accessible and we can update
it
uh for uh and it's not very pricey to
update it
uh you know after a few years so so
that's
easy now the reason why we chose srtr
was also because there was a lot
of observations and canadian data of
course you know there's a population
which is a
a lot less but we
have we do not have a registry
that is as detailed as that
which is in the states so all the
detailed data
is at the level of the hospitals so
could we do
a federated learning to to gather the
data dynamically i think
that that would be wonderful uh you know
at
shum we have a a data lake
which is uh managed by uh mikhail
chassis and his team
and so you know this is the kind of um
of a structure that could be helpful for
a project but
uh i am i know there's something like
that at mcgill as well
but i don't know uh how much of
this type of structure
there is in other centers
thank you all very much for attending
thank you very much tristan
for co-presenting with me thank you